le bon sens de l'an
est le mauvais sens de l'autre
ça c'est une petite phrase de Daniel
Debien qui est un écrivain qui est
québécois contemporain qui adepte des
petites phrases un peu simples et
pratiques comme ça le bon sens de l'un
est le mauvais sens de l'autre
alors le sens c'est très à la mode tout
le monde en veut mais personne s'accorde
vraiment à dire sur ce que c'est
alors le bon sens je vous laisse
vraiment mesurer de la subjectivité du
concept
il y a bien une définition qui dit que
le bon sens c'est la qualité d'une
personne raisonnable qui fait preuve de
jugement pratique
raisonnable pratique on lui-même
évidente alors du coup si c'est évident
en quoi le bon sens qui est évident pour
tous pour être mauvais
alors je vous invite ce soir à trois
situations où on va regarder un peu des
situations quotidiennes du bon sens puis
voir ce que ça donne
la première situation c'est quand vous
êtes pas bien vous êtes en souffrance
c'est difficile et malgré tous les
solutions de bon sens que vous essayez
non seulement ça ne s'améliore pas en
plus ça empire
exemple j'avais peur de faire cette
édition ce soir
alors au début forcément je me suis dit
n'est pas peur ça va bien se passer tu
en as d'autres soit cool et puis donne
tout ce que tu as ça à le faire quoi
ça marche pas j'avais toujours peur
alors je me suis rapprochée des
organisateurs de ce soir de ma famille
de mes confrères et qui me disait tous
pareils vas-y mais n'aie pas peur mais
enfin il y a aucune raison bien se
passer
ça marchait pas en fait au contraire
j'avais l'impression qu'ils étaient
gentil avec moi mais voilà j'avais
toujours peur je suis même allé jusqu'à
l'homéopathie franchement revenons-en
c'est pas du tout suffisant j'avais même
de plus en plus peur jusqu'à en perdre
mes moyens à me dire bah en fait
j'apprends plus j'écris plus voilà et du
coup à être dans une espèce de perte
d'énergie terrible
bon alors ça c'est le bon sens
jusqu'au moment où
j'ai pris cette carte vous connaissez le
jouait ça les étudiants c'est assez
facile voyez c'est une carte XXL de uno
ce soir parce que elle a des effets XXL
alors cette carte c'est la carte
changement de sens
et tout simplement en fait au lieu de me
dire bah arrête d'avoir peur j'ai opéré
un changement de sens
et je me suis dit bah ok tu as peur bah
vas-y viens un peu tu es qui montre toi
alors je vais vous dire
j'avais peur de me casser la figure à
l'entrée là sur cette demi-marche à côté
du poteau et puis d'arriver ici d'avoir
perdu tous mes moyens de bégayer de
faire un blanc et puis du coup que dans
le public je vous vois il y en a qui
s'endort il y en a qui sortent et puis
vous qui êtes sur Youtube mais en fait
vous commencez à écrire des commentaires
puis à rejoindre des gens sur Twitter et
puis à faire en sorte que du coup vous
rejoignez tous devant les arts et
métiers et puis que vous passiez tout
simplement la porte et que vous arriviez
en fait avec des tomates et que vous
voulez
alors là vous me dites les dwin reprend
tes esprits on est des gens raisonnables
et respectables on va pas faire ça un
peu de bon sens quoi
sauf que ça marche pas j'ai toujours
peur
alors qu'avec cette carte
je change de sens et je me dis ouais ok
tu as raison en fait ça fait hyper peur
personne n'a envie de prendre des
tomates dans la figure quand elle fait
un tennis
alors je vous invite à réfléchir
quelques secondes vous avez peut-être
cette même peur de prendre la parole en
public assez courante ou une autre et
puis simplement à vous dire dans votre
tête par rapport à cette peur ou
peut-être à murmurer si vous le voulez
ouais tu as raison
fais peur moi ça va mieux
moi ça va mieux parce que ma peur
maintenant que j'ai bien gardé en face
et que j'ai osé la déposer et ben en
fait je reprends mes esprits je reprends
mes esprits et du coup je retrouve mon
sens pratique et ma raison et puis du
coup je me rappelle cette petite phrase
que j'ai bien décidé la première fois
que je suis montée sur scène qui était
c'est pas vous qui me regardez ce soir
avec vos bonnes ou vos moins bonnes
intentions c'est moi qui suis venu vous
partager comment tromper vos cerveaux
avec art et surtout avec grande humilité
et là j'y gagne j'y gagne en confiance
en moi j'y gagne en énergie j'ai gagné
en sérénité et ça déroule
transposons cette situation dans une
salle de classe
imaginons vous monsieur vous êtes assis
devant moi dans une salle de classe et
vous n'arrêtez pas de vous retourner et
vous me faites tomber mes stylos et
tomber ma feuille et vous écrivez sur
mon bras sur ma feuille et ça vous fait
beaucoup rire
moi ça m'agace alors simplement je vais
dire arrête s'il te plaît laisse-moi
tranquille
ça marche pas il continue et en fait
plus je vous demande d'arrêter et plus
vous continuez et puis du coup le temps
monte et puis du coup bah moi je
commence à perdre mes nerfs et puis bah
sous mes aires de filles élégante je
connais quelques noms d'oiseaux donc ça
fuse
et puis du coup bah les intervenants
s'en occupent vous mettent à l'autre
bout de la salle et alors là vous prenez
un mâle un plaisir à être encore plus
créatif pour réussir à me jeter des
boulettes des machins pour faire en
sorte que du coup bah voilà la situation
perdure et soit encore plus amusante
pour vous donc finalement plus on vous
dit à
et plus vous continuez et puis moi je
perds mes nerfs et mon estime et mon
énergie
alors dans cette situation
je vais reprendre ma carte d'inversion
et je vais inverser
et plutôt que de vous dire arrête
tourner j'adore qu'on me regarde ça me
fait me sentir mais alors mais hyper
belle d'ailleurs je crois que si j'étais
toi je me retournerai vraiment parce que
effectivement je suis trop bête puis
alors tes petites grimaces en mode brut
animal là ça me fait un effet de dingue
je crois que ça marche je suis en train
de tomber amoureuse de toi allez
continue d'accord
j'ai gagné
j'ai gagné au respect
je me respecte je me fais respecter je
te respecte tu te classe il y a une
grande marque comme ça qui a joué à ça
récemment qui s'appelle grand frère une
marque de grande distribution grand
frais se sont fait piquer leur pub par
Monoprix au Qatar alors ils se sont
vraiment faire piquer leur pub parce
qu'en fait c'était même scénario même
bonhomme limite même musique même
magasin même ananas qui descend le long
des fruits et du rayon fruits et légumes
alors première réaction ils auraient pu
réagir avec bon sens en disant scandale
c'est pas possible il faut absolument
que justice soit faite
sans aucun doute ils auraient eu gain de
cause ils ont choisi une autre stratégie
ils ont inversé
et ils ont dit ouais en fait vous avez
raison allez génial notre pub mais
prenez la tous et puis d'ailleurs pour
vous aider à la prendre on vous donne
les fichiers sources ils sont
téléchargeables sur notre site Internet
vous n'avez plus qu'à mettre votre
propre logo et ça vous fait la pub
pas mal non
original et alors là gros buzz ils ont
gagné en leadership ils ont gagné en
crédibilité beaucoup plus que si tu
étais parti dans le bon sens commun
alors voyez que dans des situations
comme ça qui peuvent paraître délicates
et quand on utilise toutes nos solutions
de bon sens et que ça fonctionne pas que
ça perdure et limite ça fait pire
posons-nous la question et inversons en
fait tout simplement mais avec finesse
dans le respect pour vraiment gagner
dans la relation à l'autre
la deuxième situation qu'on va regarder
sur le bon sens c'est quand vous
souhaitez quelqu'un fasse pas quelque
chose bah vous simplement vous lui
demandez de ne pas le faire
alors là on aurait eu des cymbales on
aurait pu faire clinique tellement c'est
de l'évidence même effectivement quand
je veux pas que quelqu'un fasse quelque
chose je vais lui demander de pas le
faire essayons
s'il vous plaît ne pensez surtout pas à
une blouse grise de gadjar
vous pensez
quoi
pas mal quand même
et je vous dis maintenant pensez à la
Tour Eiffel
donc globalement que je vous dise ni
pensez pas aux pensées
à rien alors on entend souvent oui c'est
normal le cerveau n'entend pas la
négation j'ai envie d'aller un peu plus
loin et de vous dire rassurez-vous vous
êtes intelligent votre cerveau a compris
qu'il fallait pas penser à la blouse
grise jusque là tout va bien simplement
s'il pense pas à la blouse grise bah à
quoi il pense
il y a un milliard d'images qui vous
réafficher et il y a bien une chose pour
le coup que le cerveau ne peut pas faire
c'est penser à rien
ça marche pas
donc ne sachant pas quelle image
affichée il se raccroche à ce qui vient
d'entendre qui est la blouse grise
imaginez du coup l'impact d'un ne
t'inquiète pas je gère
ne pas alors j'imagine que vous
l'entendez en entreprise ou l'entendez
chez les étudiants vous le dites
peut-être même moi je l'entends avec mes
ados en mode raccourci à dos ça fait
t'inquiète maman je gère
alors moi j'entends inquiète toi il gère
que dalle
voilà ce qui se passe dans notre cerveau
donc bah du coup inquiète toi il gère
que dalle je suis sur leur dos sans
arrêt essayer de voir si si j'ai
vraiment ou s'il faudrait pas que je
m'inquiète et du coup il me disent mais
t'inquiète pas je t'ai dit de pas
t'inquiéter t'inquiète pas enfin bon du
coup ça part en vrille extraordinaire et
du coup tout le monde y perd en énergie
en relation c'est épuisant
alors mes ados je leur ai appris à
prendre une autre carte
qui est toujours celle du changement de
sens mais voyez d'une autre couleur on
est dans une autre situation et plutôt
que de dire t'inquiète je gère il me
disent maintenant
tout va bien maman je gère
je vous entends je suis pas dupe je
savais pas forcément dire que j'arrête à
chaque fois
restez méfiant pour autant je vais
passer plus de temps à aller voir si il
gère vraiment ou pas
du coup bah ils vont gagner en autonomie
ils vont gagner en liberté on va gagner
en sérénité des relations en
communication
on respire tout le monde y gagne
essayons
petite phrase au hasard vous me direz si
c'est le genre de truc que vous dites
n'hésitez pas à me contacter
vous pouvez me contacter je suis
disponible
j'ai pas disponible mardi
je suis disponible jeudi c'est mieux
faites pas la tête
sois pas en retard
sois à l'heure
ça change tout
ça change tout et je peux vous en donner
pendant une demi-heure des nœuds pas on
dit ne pas toute la journée alors là
encore il y a des grandes marques qui
ont bien compris le principe il y a
quelques temps dans le train on
entendait merci de ne pas utiliser vos
téléphones dans les wagons
ok ne pas super maintenant on a le droit
à oui au téléphone silencieux dans vos
ah du coup on sait ce qu'on doit faire
ce qu'on peut faire ah du coup on a une
règle à suivre avec plaisir plutôt
qu'une interdiction à subir
ça c'est pénible
regardez la sécurité routière il y a
encore quelques temps il disait ne
roulez pas trop vite sinon vous allez
tuer des gens
ne pas et avec un résultat de tuer donc
franchement personne n'a envie donc non
mais moi je roule pas trop vite mais de
manière même si je roule vite je gère je
vais surtout pas tuer des gens enfin
quand même pas moi je maîtrise quoi
du coup le chiffre il continue à avancer
quoi maintenant ils ont inversé et ils
ont dit
rouler doucement vous sauverez des vies
bref slogan maintenant la sécurité
routière ah sauver des vies ça ça
m'intéresse je veux bien et comment il
faut faire rouler plus doucement ok ça
rentre donc je sais que effectivement on
l'a plus doucement je vais sauver des
vies et ça va être intéressant
alors je vous rassure tout de suite le
ne pas on le dit toute la journée notre
cerveau est fait pour dire arrête pour
dire ne pas de manière automatique c'est
même limite culturel
alors je vous invite tout d'abord à
reprendre vos mails vos SMS vos affiches
vos écrits et simplement à repérer les
nœuds qui sont dedans
et puis bah inverser tout simplement
passant à la forme affirmative et voir
que vous allez vraiment gagner en impact
et en compréhension et puis si jamais ça
vous échappe et que du coup vous dites
immédiatement l'antidote ça marche ça
fera déjà le job et ce sera déjà énorme
par rapport à aujourd'hui
la troisième situation donc on va
regarder ce soir c'est quand on veut
atteindre un objectif
par exemple moi ce soir comment réussir
mon talk de ce soir bon là vous allez
dire elle devrait être contente si elle
n'y arrête ni ne pas
le faire quoi
bah effectivement comment réussir mon
TEDx ce soir c'est positif c'est
constructif ça permet d'amener vers
l'avenir c'est intéressant vous les
étudiants comment réussir votre année
les entreprises comment faire fructifier
votre entreprise comment faire en sorte
que vos managers se sentent bien ah ça
c'est des questions intéressantes alors
naturellement du coup on va aller droit
au but
par exemple moi pour ce soir comment
réussir le Talk bon bah écrire un texte
la prendre le répéter mettre
l'intonation faire en sorte que ça passe
quoi
c'est banal finalement
alors du coup j'ai opéré une nouvelle
version
une nouvelle inversion
et cette inversion elle fait comment
bien planter on s'est dit que ce soir
par exemple en prenant la carte verte au
lieu de la jaune ça marche
comment bien planter montélique ce soit
vous avez vu j'ai pas dit comment ne pas
réussir
compris ça comment bien planter mon TEDx
ce soir bon là j'ai eu plein d'idées
ah ouais effectivement j'ai eu plein
d'idées alors venir en pyjama
être deux heures en retard voir ne pas
venir du tout me moquer de vous prendre
des exemples qui sont pour les mamans de
jeunes enfants voilà j'avais une liste
et une liste là une trentaine d'exemples
alors là ça fusée alors qu'est-ce qui
fait que ça a fusée dans mon cerveau et
bah tout simplement parce que mon
cerveau fonctionne naturellement en mode
négatif c'est son mode survie
on pense d'abord aux opportunités avant
les menaces en souviens plus facilement
des moments difficiles plutôt que des
moments de joie et bas de la même
manière notre cerveau est très très
productif au mode négatif et bah servons
nous en pour du coup trouver plein
d'idées et puis une fois qu'on a trouvé
toutes ces idées et bon on reprend la
carte
et puis bah on réinverse parce
qu'effectivement c'est intéressant
d'aller dans le constructif et le
positif on est bien d'accord simplement
le chemin va pas être direct il va
passer par l'inverse pour ré inverser
et là bah du coup je trouve venir avec
une tenue appropriée vous respectez
prendre un train suffisamment à l'heure
pour pas m'énerver contre la SNCF si
jamais il y a du retard
et du coup j'arrive à des solutions très
concrètes très nombreuses très
productive et très pertinente et du coup
à une préparation beaucoup plus profonde
de cet événement de ce soir
alors vous du coup les étudiants ça
pourrait donner comment bien planter mon
année
je vous invite à vous poser la question
ça peut être ne jamais aller en cours y
aller une heure par jour arriver bourré
en cours ok ça ça va pas être fonctionné
rester dans mon coin sortir tous les
soirs
on peut en trouver plein je suis sûr que
du coup ça vous parle nickel et puis une
fois que vous avez trouvé toutes vos
idées à réinverser et du coup à dire
choisir mes jours de sortie quand il y a
pas cours demain prendre des notes quand
je suis en classe m'intégrer et partager
avec les autres étudiants et là du coup
vous aurez une préparation plus
intéressante et plus complète
et puis vous en entreprise je vous
invite à vous poser la question à
l'envers comment bien planter mon
entreprise
comment mettre la clé sous la porte
comment faire fuir tous mes salariés
comment contribuer au réchauffement
climatique c'est pas mal aussi
est-ce que vous êtes déjà posé la
question dans ce sens
alors je vais vous donner une autre
définition du coup du bon sens qui est
la qualité d'une personne qui discerne
et qui trouve ses opinions en évaluant
alors tout simplement la prochaine fois
que vous serez dans une situation où en
fait vous êtes mal et malgré tout ce que
vous faites dans le bon sens bah ça
continue voir ça fait pire dans une
situation où vous avez demandé à
quelqu'un de pas faire quelque chose et
puis qu'il le fait
ou dans une situation dans laquelle vous
souhaitez atteindre un objectif et vous
trouvez pauvre en idée pour y arriver
ou dans n'importe quel autre situation
qui vous mène à un mur
je vous invite simplement à évaluer le
bon sens dans lequel vous êtes parti
et puis pourquoi pas
inverser et puis bah
c'est gagné
merci